speaking of streams and time
heraclitus is river this is mentioned
quite a bit in your book
and i have a speculative question here
it's okay i'm just going to read it
because i don't have it in my working
memory so the right brain is the type
that when i say right brain i mean
hemisphere so the right hemisphere is
the type that would come up with the
statement that there's unceasing change
it's constantly constantly changing and
then the left is the one that needs to
stand back and abstract and see some
constancy
and then it made me think about time and
then the arrow of physics
and i'm wondering if you had any
thoughts on the nature of time or the
nature of era of time and physics
well
i do curt but i i don't know how
how good they are but i i've thought
about it an enormous amount
and
physicists themselves are divided on the
arrow of time but i tend to be with
those who say that without the arrow of
time nothing could mean or be anything
at all that all that we know
of physics even down to the you know the
most rarefied kind of contemporary
physique
none of it could be without the
existence of time there could be no
processes in fact without time and i
believe that this processes are prior to
things which is partly why i entitled
this book the matter with things
it's a pun on various levels because i
think there's a problem with our
material obsession and there's a problem
with our thinking the world is made up
of things
so i think
you know i don't take the block theory
of time you know that it's really a
static thing but we just move about it
nor do i take the view that
um
it's it's
it's something that most of the
philosophers who've tried to approach
time
with the single exception of bergson
seem to me to have
confused what they're talking about and
unfortunately most people nowadays don't
read bergson and the reason they don't
read bergson is they've inherited a
prejudice that somehow bergson
was wrong because he had a debate with
einstein in which it said he didn't
understand einstein but which is equally
true that einstein didn't understand
bergson
they were looking at two different
things and they weren't necessarily at
odds with one another
einstein was looking at a kind of time
like a clock's time
whereas
bergson was looking at time
as not something that can be measured in
that way and
the distinction between a flow
and a series
is absolutely fundamental and bergson
spent most of his life trying to
help people see why this was so
fundamental and when i saw it it was
absolutely one of the three or four
great eureka moments of my life
i saw that a lot of the problems that we
have philosophically speaking and with
our attitude to the world come from us
having seen
a seamless motion as a concatenation of
an infinite number of slices that sounds
like an almost technical difference but
in fact
it goes right to the core
of the two
versions of the world that come into
being because the left hemisphere
is always trying to stop time it's
always trying to freeze time because
imagine its idea is to pick something up
or to catch something so it it wants to
freeze it and catch it and get it and
have it and hold it
but you know as goethe said as blake
said when you try to freeze the fleeing
moment then you're lost
because all is in this
process of
change and flow and it's respecting that
and attuning yourself with it that is
wise not trying to resist it or pretend
it doesn't exist
so those are some of my thoughts about
time